dans cette main territoire nous sommes
pas venus sinon à éradiquer du mois à
contenir voire à faire reculer la menace
dialyse dans d'autres territoires en
revanche cette menace se développe
depuis 2013 la france est engagée au
sahel pour contenir la menace terroriste
pourquoi la france victorieuse des
terroristes islamistes en 2013 ne se
retire toujours pas
la france intervient militairement au
mali dès 2013 avec l'opération serval
pour endiguer l'avancé des islamistes
vers le sud
cette opération est une réussite à
partir de 2014 l'opération servent à les
remplacer par l'opération barkan avec
4500 soldats répartis dans tout le sahel
de la mauritanie au tchad
c'est aujourd'hui la plus importante
opération de la france à l'étranger pour
prêter main forte aux soldats français
et combattre ces mouvements djihadistes
viennent s'ajouter treize mille casques
bleus ainsi que les troupes de cinq pays
africains appelés le g5 sahel à paris on
souhaite que cette force en place à
terme l'armée française sur le terrain
le relais semble difficile à mettre en
place le principe barkan dès le départ
c'est que l'armée française met à niveau
les groupes djihadistes baisse leurs
puissances pour qu'elles soient
apportées le combat des armées
africaines qui elles mêmes vont 38 ans
et d'autres trouver un moyen pour que
les forces locales contre le contrôle du
territoire
donc le g5 sel c'est un moyen proposé
par la france pour que les pays de la
région cette large bande sahélienne qui
est grande comme l'europe qu'elle puisse
contrôler la zone où pullulent les
terroristes le problème aujourd'hui qui
a c'est que les armées africaines -
l'armée malienne l'armée burkinabé ne
montent en puissance tandis que les
groupes vialis ne descendent pas
vraiment de poids pendant ce temps la
menace continue de croître
au départ le nord du mali est divisé en
trois groupes aqmi dans la ville de
tessalit l'ujao dans la ville de kidal
est interdit dans la vie de gao de ses
anciens groupes islamistes se sont
unifiés
ils sont désormais affilié à al qaïda et
mène
l'état islamique peu à peu il ya une
entrée qui était déjà amorcée en 2012
2013 dans le corps social malien donc de
plus en plus c'est pas des étrangers
c'est pas des arabes mais de plus en
plus des noirs donc c'est une vraie
différence est de plus en plus ce sont
des locaux ce sont des maliens
existentiellement des peuls ont peu à
peu le le conflit s'est répandu dans le
tout payé ce qui permet évidemment
d'avoir beaucoup plus d'acteurs donc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile à contenir
et une guerre à mener parce que tout
départ marque à une chasse finalement
les petits groupes isolés dans le désert
et aujourd'hui c'est des gens assez
important répartis dans tout le centre
du manifeste sous la terreur une grâce
au conflit interethnique
grâce aux conflits sociaux ils
fournissent car ce trafic de drogue
aussi dîné à l'avarié des revenus aux
populations locales qui sans idéologie
sangatte simplement c'est un employeur
s'il sur place les petits groupes qui se
restructurent qui se réorganise et qui
prospère sur les faillites et des
faiblesses des sociétés locales et la
manière est mise en cause pour sa
gestion de la situation
la situation en 2013 quand à la france
d'intervenir le signe que l'état malien
n'est pas en mesure de contrôler son
territoire une vraie difficulté pour le
président malien ibrahim boubacar keita
à s'imposer il ne semble pas parvenir à
imposer un cadre imposer ses idées et on
le voit bien il
non dans le processus de paix il ya un
accord de paix quand même que l'accord
de paix d'alger fêté il ya près de
quatre ans et dont
la mise en oeuvre la mise en place est
pratiquement au point mort c'est un état
qui est touchée par la corruption aussi
donc à une partie des équipements des
aides peuvent être fournis sur place qui
ne sont pas transférés sur le terrain
notre exemple et les militaires maliens
ont souvent de métier ils sont
militaires ils ont aussi un commerce
donne envie c'est là où la france n'a
pas la main à ce qu'elle a du mal à
inciter le mali à aller plus vite dans
sa réorganisation pire malgré les forces
en présence la contagion du djihad s'est
déjà étendue aux pays frontalier du mali
le burkina faso et le niger et menace de
se propager dans tout le continent
africain
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la logique
de répartition des groupes qui sont
présents dans le centre du mali puis
dans les deux provinces qui vont vers
gao descendre plutôt vers le sud donc
vers le burkina faso la province du soum
d'eisai sur l'apport en style très
pointu katrina et on les voit arriver
par l'est du burkina faso presque
jusqu'aux portes du bénin dont il ya
plus une musique de descendre vers le
sud du continent que vers le sud du mali
la france souhaite collaborer avec ses
voisins européens même si ces états ne
sont pas confrontés de manière directe à
l'extension de la menace terroriste
ils détiennent une partie de la solution
pour la cobac une opération de meta
coups bas pour permettre à la france de
sortir de son isolement dans la zone
mouvante et française d'élargir la
mission est d'associer d'autres pays
européens en dehors du mandat devenu
pour que l'état doit les allemands
d'autres mais d'année puissent
s'associer sur le terrain et renforcer
les capacités militaires
la france a perdu 32 personnes dans ce
conflit trente-deux militaires je suis
pas sûr beaucoup de pays européens
soient prêts à ça à l'exception de la
grande bretagne
alors est-ce qu'un désengagement des
forces armées au sel est possible il
faut que la sécurité de la france soit
assurée ce qui veut dire que sur le
terrain les groupes terroristes n'existe
plus nous avons une menace pour l'europe
le chef d'état major a très bien dit que
pour lui c'était quelque chose qui était
envisageable à l'horizon 10 ans 15 ans
donc il est clair que pour l'instant la
france semble s'engager dans un temps
l'eau